well jason maybe you can walk us through
what you would do
for your job to prepare for a remote
what about the kevin hart remotes right
this ride-along yeah the first one was
is it actually
because we had never done anything like
that before and we knew the first one
was the lift
lift the lift driver we knew we were
going to call a lift we knew we were
going to be on a corner somewhere meet
these guys yeah right and then we were
going to call a lift and the driver
might come and say no like we knew we
nothing was planned beforehand that was
all real that's another thing and we
also had these you know conan kevin hart
and ice cube waiting there like we
didn't want to make them wait long
what part of town were you in right in
hollywood yeah in hollywood but i
remember like days before um
our camera guys seth and james seth st
vince and james palchesky and our audio
jason eunice chase munoz we practice
because we were setting up because we
didn't want them wait it was almost like
a pit stop so we i remember
driving around our stage at stage 15 in
a car
and pretending never time i mean like oh
this guy just agreed to let us set up
cameras in his car yeah
how fast so we yeah we got it down to
like 10 minutes
literally did it like a pit stop like a
pit crew it's really like that's amazing
well because and so what you're saying
is it was not planned in advance who
this correct driver was who the driver
would be because if we had planned it
then with the card of infections
exactly so you had to probably would
have been about but we really wanted the
reality yeah yeah and and so so the
practice actually i mean they got faster
and faster and faster when this guy came
they got it set up pretty quickly and
yeah we the rest of us jumped in a van
and we just we followed we were in a
follow-up
as far as permits go like that's when
you're driving around the city and
you're not interfering with anything
it's just you just go yeah
and so how many gopros were there like i
think there was two in the front yeah um
i think there was two in the back like
seeing side angles or something right
and then
and then we had a camera in the van
there was a camera in the van but then
they put one like outside getting like
tires and stuff right right yeah
yeah yeah yeah pretty stuff yeah yeah
but um we can't start to leave that tire
shot but then the audio guy had to put
his like rig in the trunk there is a
receiver had to be in the truck
yeah and we and if our van got too far
away
our follow van got too far away from
them talking we heard static we didn't
hear anything like we had a video yeah
driving it was just going through red
lights and just dragging through the
sting operation yeah we're going to stay
as close as possible and then oh sorry
no i was going to ask if jason uh were
you involved in screening the
driver
when you um well once he
we were kind of like if someone agrees
it's going
um i don't remember who the writers were
on that we taught it
i i went you asked me okay just you know
yeah yeah and then the first guy we got
we liked
we just liked him yeah he seemed like a
cool guy yeah i so so much of
so much of remotes is just live
it's just luck and you run and seeing
where it goes and open to it there's so
many iconic
iconic but within the conan world of you
know remote moments of meeting people
where people think oh well that that
person's a plan and it's like no
it's just we just shot a lot of other
stuff that we cut out right right right
also jason you got so great at
at talking to someone over the like when
we when we were gonna get like
shooting like one of my all-time
favorite remotes is conan's commercial
audition oh yeah oh yeah
okay i have a question about seafood
shrimp if i say 21 shrimpers at 21
shrimp or 21 shrimps i've got to know
because there's this great tasting
dinner going on right now the
international house of pancakes and i
need to know
i was trying to go fast i saw to make
room for the paws that i took
how'd that work
well you know how it worked so you're
asking me how that work is a dick move
you know you were calling around
different there's so many is that at tbs
that was a tbs yes yeah there's so many
you know in l.a there's so many yeah
commercial
and i i you caught but you would just
get this sixth sense where you're like i
think this guy is going to be good and
you nailed it every time
but but yes so much of the like the man
in the street stuff is that's all just
lost yeah on timing yeah just
waiting it out hanging out on the street
for a while right although usually that
stuff it helps that he's famous
yep because it would he detract but even
i got those travel shows we're talking
about the travel shows here like we i
mean how lucky we always got lucky in
those we did yeah it seemed like almost
like it wasn't luck yeah right except
japan where not a single person knew
nobody knew who he was we didn't if you
watch the show in japan there's not it's
like hey where's the usual man on the
street stuff because no one would even
look at him right but like the family we
bought you know the family to be his
family were all i mean they were great
they were all great oh that that could
have been you know we could have there
was an article in new york or about you
can rent i saw that yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then uh
he
uh so we went to that service and then
he just yeah he just picked some people
yeah and it's just they met him at his
hotel room that was in some family and
they turned out to be great great but
that stuff like that happened so many
times right butcher guy and you know
like
oh the the butcher guy
oh you can eat you can eat it's very
good it's raw
yeah
yes why don't you go first
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean part of it is conan's
yeah
super fast at reading of course but but
also
yeah it's
just a lot of luck involved